in the previous episode I want to do
that I want to do that
we're going to ninokuni oh it's a tree
that was actually a surprising that's a
[ __ ] duck tree what the [ __ ] that is
surprise to the house of your own breath
welcome back to Nina [ __ ] Cooney
thank you very much
old father oak but simply passes
possessing the page a particular spell
is no guarantee that you will be able to
make use of it some spells are simply
not meant for sudden visit shells is
life such as life is [ __ ] moving in
the background what's up what that
Oliver is blinded by the darkness of
their wizard he's still do it anyway um
yeah we just learn to spell from this
duck tree don't worry about it for now
Mun just give form familiar with you
sure thing mr. drippy alright so we now
have a new spell it's called form
familiar doesn't that make it excited
that doesn't make you excited what makes
you excited oh never mind
you dirty you daddy daddy what I know my
what is e magic cuckoo nothing [ __ ] soya
oh my no control nucleoside diphosphate
since you know see happen in our time
it's beautiful
it looks pretty useless to me that cape
he's awesome oh my oh no Tara
oh you don't have to clean Wow is he
going to look more badass because I
don't think that's possible
[ __ ] all the demon spawns will run away
when they see this guy so this is
familiar huh and he'll be coming with us
in dearly well Olli boy the more the
merrier ain't it here you better give it
a little element oh I know what you're
gonna be let's go with Stefan it's not
really so far no it's justified Holloway
you cannot let you we cannot let this
set off in the wild where with only that
way the volume yet let me give you some
spells Eddie in the battle the first one
it's the Nonna's healing touch all right
thanks I'll give it after blazing found
a fireball shoot the level fire that one
does plant based PC fire run even old
tree face hair is scared of fire ball
directly how dare you how dare you you
would never aim such a spell on me would
you boy golly of course not all father
where the [ __ ] are ya another Pokemon we
have to kill it
category fire Latonya Odie Odie ba it's
like the cutest thing ever
as I tell it when I look at that that
guy you like magic that guy it looks
high as [ __ ] whoa whoa do I play as him
or do teeny Boober 18mp stuff ah right o
Allah boy it's time to learn about
fighting with familiars first up you got
to pick up where okay Wow the spell is
called cut nose okay good job so fun now
I will attack this one hey ha the fan
[Music]
attack him that one attack that one too
and then nu attacked her and then
canceled it and then attack a gas Jaya
[Music]
that was a little more tricky because of
a lot of things to do it once but I
think I got it oh my god it level up
stuff on level up to level 2 I Love You
Stefan I love you it's so Bureau so now
you know how to fight with a familiar
ain't it only boy to be a true contender
you'll need to learn when to let your
familiar loose and when to take control
over yourself I'll do my best mr.
dripping hi it's a cure the courage gave
you can shower
it's like a Tom Iguchi ok there's all
kind of treats to choose from some will
improve their abilities I even teach
them new tricks and the balance of
familiar between you and girl meaning
that's cute
careful not to stuff them too much
they'll end up getting full up that's
the key moderation it's probably a lot
to get your head around but just ruin it
create we're like ok creatures got it
promise look after him real well mr.
drippy all right cool this game just
gets cooler and cooler and less game
playing game I'm just kidding I'm broken
how do you say share this better blah
blah blah
I [ __ ] love with each and such ha ha
patient John baby of course I have let
me know see now hmm I know it's here
somewhere
crikey you've not gone and lost it have
you lost it there insolent
I put it away safely among my upper monk
branches it's just a little tangle up
there that's all ah while I sing it out
have a I have a favor I did mention
we're flipping hurry denied well I
haven't gotten time to go message FA mr.
Draper we can have our Father home he
gave us a spell today wow we're fresh
meats never irresponsible honest young
man I'm a doctor alright alright I get
the flippin massacre
go on if it's near fudged well it's
guarded say got it well off then I'm
friends with glutton well well well
that's no good is it
we'd rather helps out a male named
Guardian he sounds kind of tough to ride
she is is way stronger than your average
beastie you got a familiar area on your
side now Mun you'll be fine
and besides go to take a down shader you
can't go back out a little bit guarding
your bench now can you okay I'll do it
it's very easy to convince Tolliver how
very kind of you the guarding had been
found in the deepest part of the void
beyond the Whispering waterfall give you
what you like this is [ __ ] go form
familiar what do we got fireball whoa
whoa cool
sorry all right well back we go oh look
pretty flowers pretty flower it's like
gum and the away can we go here now cool
we can cool
what happens here it's a just did it it
it it it it it it it it it it it it it
it 1104 Brown
I know I'm not supposed to go here but I
can't help myself it's an adventure
breast you can't skip out on everything
in life can you what's going on here a
loading screen whoa
whispering waterfalls ok I'm going back
because I don't think we're supposed to
be here so now that we made it through
all that text we can actually play and
kill people aren't you happy it's nobody
look at that he likes gets the beach
lepida / wants it what is that all right
we must approach him very slowly let's
not make it found us as a very cool
cookie it's like the cutest - creature
ever and we're gonna [ __ ] murder it
aspic - Yosh gum baton oh yeah I know I
know it can be cake it did it Justin -
dirt dirt dirt dirt dirt dirt it attack
him you're doing it wrong Oliver you
suck Oliver yeah keep attacking that one
and then again attack him - I thought
they could attack at the same time
alright we need to help heal ah [ __ ]
alright here we go
don't want to die now that we got a
spouse healing touch whoa nail that bed
I like that it's not turn-based because
it bores the [ __ ] out of me if it's
turn-based go stéfano kill that [ __ ]
kept attacking and then we is Oliver to
use the healing Sun Oh
ah [ __ ] it I'm a little bit [ __ ] up
here but it's okay good job Savannah oh
[Music]
we got a white bread we might as well he
loved then all right cool we got full
health that it's a little trickier
battles I wonder if you will get armor
and shed probably oh [ __ ] a chest did it
it it it it it it it it it it it it it
it it it a chocolate chocolate chocolate
chopped oh we we [ __ ] sick up on that
[ __ ] they did not seen this
makini oh look at those asses oh look at
that at it it gets the fun
shuts the Fond retreat use the Cutler's
attack whoa we had ears like they're
just standing there being noobs and shed
attacks upon Stefan is Stefan owes a lot
more powerful honestly oh I wonder
what's gonna happen when I finish with
the game it's gonna be like nothing I
don't know I'll stuff our level up to
level three so far your you can't level
up before me don't you just hate when
you play with friends and they level up
before you and you're like what the [ __ ]
are you doing crikey I know something I
forgot to tell you about familiar what
is that it's a portal boys a lesson
carefully what the little fellas get
stronger they start learning new ones if
you want to see what tricks for Miller's
Oh level 10 okay and he's level okay you
can't do anything right now oh [ __ ] not
a two at once oh no I'm gonna get [ __ ]
daddy me has the upper hand the
croissant
nice nice yeah what's that a tree what's
that [ __ ] at No
a crunchy carrot wonderful
we should probably eat something how do
we eat have ago that was easy wonderful
did it it it it it it it it it it it it
it it it it a wide no her bread are we
getting there let's check the man yeah
we're getting there don't worry breasts
we're almost there I see her being all
patient on patient than [ __ ] all right
so let's sneak up on this oh it's a sigh
doc machetes oh he doesn't know how to
walk here
very interesting attack him it looks
like he's kissing my janitor that's okay
that nice dad alright let's kill him
bras Stephon she'll do it for us bread
goes to pot well done - [ __ ] - easy bras
- easy
[Music]
da-da-da-da-da-da nay libras nailed our
batch raw almost there almost there
we just gotta fight our way through like
the epic battle music save that bed
state got a llama shave Hey look at that
ballerina I think he was born a
ballerina in a previous life do you
brats believe that you were like lived
in another life when you were young and
not when you were younger but in another
life and stuff I don't believe in it but
I think if I was born at something else
I would be born as said as if I don't
even know you can tell me hola Paulie
boy what is it
lesson man so much coming it's him it's
the flipping Guardian look at him
oh [ __ ] it's the [ __ ] Guardian even
the side Doc's are scared oh [ __ ]
I wonder how he's gonna look like what I
can't kill no not the side action no way
we can beat that the fun is gonna get us
the guardian of the woods stead defender
of forest fire ball spell on that [ __ ]
fireball spell I'll handle this
spells fireball that [ __ ] [ __ ] up on
whoa that was close
fireball that beard shitali oh ha ha
Oh windfall knickers this upstairs I
best defend that's what it's for
yes just a flippin
nice nice defending against big ones
like that can earn a nice little bonus
as well cool
fireball that beard okay
Stefano I choose your Pikachu attack
that [ __ ] okay for their tiny little
stick yeah it's too tired to give a [ __ ]
girls the bus
Oh chiffon Japan Japan
nice now it's my chance to do what the
[ __ ]
look on you buy the big love I'll go no
no now's your chance to give me the
proper way laughing hmm
just prop up a looping huh attack
oh I did one debit to damage three
damage for out others hell from their
castle at windfall Japan depended how
nice
what's up games us now's your chance
recharging go back to Oliver and Oliver
shall use the fire bah ha ha ha charger
my fire on 19 what's up what's up I'm
gonna go full front on that bed Abbot
really hard to go back and never mind
bad idea get more mana get my banner I
tell you I'll chop I would what defend
Oh your head hurt
missed missed no I don't want cut loose
on that veggies that was terrible
Stephano retreat Stephano [ __ ] ah
healing touch on that [ __ ]
[Music]
yes we needed that one there's some more
health over here grab it
okay the fan miss me there semana I want
to finish him off with our fire spell de
pan that batch
nice hahahaha
that's your touch okay alright fireball
my charlie my fire about nineteen what's
up a gold lamé where where oh there
that's cool I didn't need it
I'm taste too close come on
Oh he throws him out
alright she's a fireball again yay and
then witch witch back to Joseph on the
fan
oh no safaris stunned by this kind what
are you doing I might have a [ __ ]
attack in
oh sure that's a lot if you don't defend
oh well now's your chance
challenge the bots off better job
alright let's finish him off
I are bottom you went down to funk
appeared tail that was an awesome boss
battle that was really enjoyable ha ha
ha no wow wow look at that [ __ ] I
leveled up like a bear good job good job
my god Stefano's level 5 now breath can
you believe it you can't believe it
you're speechless my god
cool I got a page describing how to kill
him but he's not dead yet
we must kill him properly he's like [ __ ]
dad guard come on man I just wanted to
play
cranky that was close run thing Mon the
Guardian here the towards the deepest
part of the would you think is back for
normal now you're a good it gives it
gives my mind but that we're looking as
I had gone at least I reckon he probably
takes some time out to get his head
together and then I'll be back to the
old guard old Guardian but that what
made him go all screwy like that you
don't think it was of course it was a
flippin shader written all over let's
watch our backs while we waited for is
saying your God is everywhere anyway we
did the way came for a wedding we're
back to schrieffer's huh alright let's
go back to tree face I'd say duck face
though I'd say duck face is name the
serenity of the God in words heart has
unlocked a story of wizard companion bad
I have chained a new tail my butt and I
got an achievement i press thank you for
watching this episode it was quite
enjoyable Oh duck face you will have to
pause one second
like vision joy subscribe to become a
brown today and I'll see you next
episode of live I love you bro
stay awesome